good to see ya a man good to see you are  you having a good New Year's so far yeah  man I'm just happy that other year is  over yeah it's tough here huh it was  tough for everybody but it's super weird  for me because I'm an old metal nerd  from the 80s and so that we here was so  weird because now Biff from Back to the  Future 2 is our president you know and  Metallica and Star Wars are awesome  again I don't know what to think  I want to Peter Parker's aunt yeah Aunt  May is awesome now it's Marissa - oh  yeah okay all right  my whole life she was this weird old  lady and kind of a bummer and now it's  Marissa Tomei and I don't know what to  think you're breakin fuse okay  you